it's white yep what does that mean maybe
you guys are having a white baby that's
awesome congratulations
garrett said that he was going to take
care of the gender reveal so we just got
a regular cake
i made the melon baby
karen
what is it
uh
i don't know
what
i mean i i mean i don't know
you don't know the doctor doesn't even
know
what is gender anyway right it's just a
construct i mean look around we got
football you got ballet you guys are
writing this baby's code before it even
comes out you're perpetuating gender
stereotypes
how about we let this kid figure out its
own gender
you guys should be ashamed of yourselves
pick up the intercom and say
i don't know um strawberry jam ooh but
what if something actually happens with
strawberry jam i am willing to take that
chance excuse me are you the store
manager heck yeah i am guy i found a
thumb in my guacamole
strawberry jam
hey so random i was going through some
old security footage with luanne yeah
and you remember how we used to have
those security cameras in the break room
well we came across the time you let all
my birds escape
uh
yeah
remember that remember it was
valentine's day remember i was blaming
myself for it and then when i was at my
lowest you had sex with me knowing that
hours before you were the one that let
them out and you knew the entire time
and yet you said nothing remember that
that's so funny
dina i'm so so sorry hey come on don't
even worry about it i forgive you when
you think about it this whole thing is
just funny
hey come with me i want to show you
something
they went up so fast it's like they
wanted to burn
what's that sound is that air escaping
from the sneakers
it almost sounds like they're screaming
i will never forgive you
ever
oh
beige that's a crazy color for a towel
nice
and you got one of this
oh lady hey let me dig in your basket
attention cloud9 shoppers there is a
carbon monoxide leak in the store
it's the silent killer so you're going
to want to go
hey uh
i'm sorry about the whole intercom thing
i got carried away and
it wasn't cool
it's okay um maybe we both cared more
about this thing between us than we
wanted to admit
it is possible yeah and maybe what i
actually need as i'm processing this
tornado stuff is not to be alone but to
have some support
are you saying you want to get back
together
i mean
is that crazy
i don't think so let's do it
okay
yeah this isn't working out i'm dumping
you what you're dumped unambiguous sir
did you just see that i dumped him
attention cloud9 employees we have a
non-verbal confirmation i dumped garrett
you're a monster enjoy wine club
this is so stupid
all of these videos are stupid not
everything needs to be documented look
at where i am okay what i ate for lunch
today nobody cares we're all becoming
these narcissistic attention how
about we okay at some point she's got to
see the rats one another well you know
what watch
don't watch i don't care but if you like
what you saw you can follow me on
snapchat instagram and twitter i'm at
cloud9ed
i don't think she saw the rats
i don't think so attention cloud9
shoppers we have a bit of an emergency
in the middle of something right now
attention employees we need you to
assemble in the front of the store for a
group photo in 10 minutes
and look sharp we haven't we have a
chance to have ceo neil penderson in our
store this is not a prank neil patterson
as i was saying there's a missing child
his name is kaden he has brown hair he's
eight years old and is wearing overalls
so uh
i guess those two things group photo
missing kit
hey glenn there's a customer here who
wants to talk to a man okay
hello glenn sturgis speaking yes this is
martin nestle
hello mr nestle trace this call yeah i
don't have that technology i signed up
for a blue card and i think i may have
given the wrong email
okay well thank you for calling to tell
us are you tracing this call
while i have you on the phone what did
you think of the employee who signed you
up
his name's matteo
and i think he's a real dummy a class a
stinker what do you say about me
oh
mr sturgis i need to get back to work oh
okay then well
have a heavenly day
well who are you talking to
martin
leslie oh
lost the trace what do you love what do
you hate let's do hate first uh
i hate war
well that's a bold stance
how about more like how about this place
what's the worst part about working here
i guess not seeing my son all day
that'll work
over in patio furniture we're going to
have
uh
my bad y'all that reaction was very out
of character for me um normally a very
cool guy
i have a lot of cool sneakers and
a very active sex lab
well here are some defenses that are
used in detention cases involved in
community service active organ donor yes
exactly so we just need to think if
mateo fits into anything like
that or we could just embellish a little
and it wasn't easy but mateo managed to
teach those inner city kids how to
express themselves
through the power of
music are you just telling me to plot
the sister act 2 back in the habit yes
which i heard is loosely based on
mateo's life
so that's
wild
that's why if it was up to me i'd fire
half the staff no don't put that on the
cake glenn make him stop see not so
cocky now are you dina i swear to god
one of these days i'm going to strangle
you i'd like to see
you try is that a threat you threaten me
careful i'm being careful i don't need
you to tell me to be careful
all right here we go
nice job all right
see the trick is
steady hands
i was going to be a surgeon but
nope
[Music]
they're getting
come back
[Music]
you